what's going on there
citizens of the reject nation
john how are you
i'm even better now than i was a minute
ago i'm good i'm great g how are you
doing good good
just follow my phone
label out here and then try and drink it
backwards yeah let it be known we drink
jeep this video is not sponsored by
cheap
but we drink g-fuel everyone and brands
intervene on your daily life whether
they've never protected you you never
know hey we got two things from she-hulk
to look at today apparently they just
released the opening scene and the final
scene
now we can speculate in the middle and
so we're going to watch just the opening
scene and that was released on imdb
twitter at least that's where i found it
and there's also a new trailer
featurette thingy that was really some
marvel entertainment page leave a like
hulk smash that like button or
thunder clap it and hey let's get to it
we are going to be covering this show
next week koi zhandra will be joining us
so yeah
in the marvel cinematic universe the
people are protected by two separate yet
equally important groups the heroes who
save them and the attorneys who clean up
their collateral damage but only one can
be both
this is her story
she holds illegal comedy like we've
never done before
all rise
back now
all right aura calm down
what's fun is the types of marvel
characters that come to her for legal
advice no judge is going to take this
seriously unless we do things by the
book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american uh loss
it's a law show the galley mcpheel or
the practice
and then it breaks all those rules your
dad worked on the practice yeah i was
about to say
this legal world and all of the
possibilities around superhero weirdness
call my lawyer
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer
we're really pushing boundaries other
shows haven't before what boundaries hey
it's close
[Music]
how's dodc
[Music]
done
there
so
back to what i was saying before
my theory oh god um steve rogers did not
have a girlfriend before he went into
the service oh god they're doing it
the history channel so he becomes
captain america and from that moment on
a symbol of america he is rushed to the
front lines he becomes a war hero then
he is frozen in ice right so based on
everything you've told me um after he
gets unfrozen he goes from
world-threatening disaster to
world-threatening disaster that's when
he's not a fugitive from the law right
so it seems like he was pretty pretty
busy all you're doing is repeating
everything that i've already told you
about my friend and colleague obviously
captain america wasn't oh [ __ ]
the grand master
the cheetos
oh wow golly there's a lot to take from
that one scene yeah there's more
that was a grand mastership wasn't it am
i wrong about that i think i'm right
about that i think you're right about
that but i would need to check because i
know that thor ragnarok took elements of
the planet hulk storyline bruce banner
getting captured the air force being
gladiator matches and stuff he's
probably not the grand master it could
be someone who wants revenge against the
hulk yeah or whatever yeah have it be
that thor and hulk are both supposed to
be there duking it out they're under
contract as prisoners maybe he wants to
sue them and that's probably this yeah
you showed up to drop papers
it's all related yeah um it's gotta be
and then i'm assuming due to that car
accident is why the blood transfusion
moment would happen yes because maybe a
gunshot wound is a little too much yeah
yeah i think there's a storyline
god my memory is so jagged on on some of
this i think there's a story line that
does sort of involve that with his son
which is not so car's weird video
because this is me
my memory it's his son
i don't think it's a young avengers
titan i think it's scar
like with a k okay it's been a long time
guys like it's like way back to thor
ragnarok okay we can't all be coy i know
i know uh he's just constantly rereading
it was working he's just got four books
open like one and just like levitating
above his body reading comics i'm not
sure but it looks like they're going to
be tying it in and making bruce banner's
story more essential which makes the
responsibility factor of this tie into
it more so i'm wondering how much of it
are they really going to link it
qualities because to have the ship from
sakaar show up here on earth i'm gonna
be building up a new hulk movie out of
it but the main thing is the captain
america virginity jokes haha we he's
getting out of the first team to get
there no he was a [ __ ] is that what
they were saying is that he was a virgin
he must have been a virgin were they
saying he was a virgin yeah because when
would he found the time to make it
she was saying that he had a lot of
action oh i thought the point was she's
like when would he have had time to to
meet and and
hold on form a romantic bond let me hear
this last part again obviously captain
america was a virgin all right okay
which i thought the joke was that he is
was that all these things made him such
a badass that he would have had to have
gotten like tons of time when she said
he's
the avengers ride thinking they had paul
rudd acknowledged the
famous thing uh they handed them to a
joke about that first of all
gross
so i thought that they were saying like
okay you know people make jokes about
cat being a virgin but he actually
wasn't he was actually really busy
um but then now that i hear it back like
oh no he was too busy to get laid yeah
yeah yeah and he's also got the whole
peggy carter thing what about during
world war i i mean yeah or
wouldn't he have i feel like he would
while he was like touring his like
captain america the sideshow yeah he'd
have some down time there'd be a red
light district somewhere he could go to
maybe he could have been in a bar you
know struck up a conversation with a
nice young lass overseas
part of me look at that movie with all
of his illegitimate children coming out
of the woodwork part of me wishes that
james gunn uh produced this show
produced i say specifically because it
sounds like the cameos that we're going
to be getting or some of them might be
like some of the weirdest most obscure d
grade
marvel characters
because i was going to say what like
there are at least a couple appearances
during the actual court scene like with
the guy who who makes like the poof yeah
of smoke and there's like the girl who
leans up who like look kind of like
like a wanda variant or something in an
instant but you know
not no that's not elizabeth olsen it
wouldn't be
but but at the same time i don't know i
can't tell you that i don't know how i
feel about the way they were doing tim
roth's voice with abomination i need to
see more of it in context yeah and i get
that with hulk he sounds normal but they
at least redesigned hulk to look a
little different before they had him
just sounding like mark ruffalo yeah i'm
like this looks like exactly abomination
from shanghai and everything and
uh even like the updated version but
still reminds you of the one from the
hulk movie
but just has tim ross
just learned to talk
a little weird yeah yeah for sure what
is the character continuity going to be
because even though this is a comedy and
it's fair to stretch the broader
elements yeah i mean
you would need some kind of explanation
at least as to how he's made such leaps
and bounds in articulation i don't know
this show looks great i don't care what
anyone says it looks like a lot of fun
yeah man i'm really excited and i mean
you know like there's the odd effect
shot where you're like oh i don't know
but like if the show is good and the
performances are good like it'll be like
physical makeup like there were times
where like i could sell those guys in
makeup but i don't care because it's
good material it's all about tone yeah
all right guys well i enjoyed this this
was fun
i'm really doubting myself on those
things
don't worry
whatever you're doubting yourself on i'm
doubting myself thrice is my i i had a
total mulligan just there i'm like
what's party wanda who's party wanda
with wong over there it's not wanda i
know it's not wanda but for a second
there i don't know something about what
she's doing she looks like one
all right guys
are you excited for it leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell leave a like
hey let's do a patreon
flev tavious doran flev you're a marvel
guy but also
a demon slayer guy and i had to choose
people to shout out the video i was like
i don't know but so today i wanted to
make you a twofer bud you are such an
enthusiastic lovely cat and you would
never needly
yeah you nasty dirty illegal boy you
flev dory a string yeah i want chase i
want to watch you represent yourself in
court but where did the laser go yeah
he's just off from chasing a ball of
yarn chasing lasers come back and focus
buddy
you're just so cute though you're just
so cute look the way you experience
everything is endearing i just can't get
enough of your experience of life and
sometimes i wish i could jump inside
your body and look up at the world and
go yeah
i think we nailed this video killed in
the game congratulations best video of
the year
[Music]